OK, so I want to talk a little bit today about
Republican Congressman Dan Crenshaw.
He was on the Joe Rogan program not that long
ago, and he said a bunch of stuff that really
didn't make sense about socialism and health
care.
And Joe Rogan pretty effortlessly sort of
made mincemeat of Dan Crenshaw's arguments.
And I did a story about it and there was great
interest in it.
And clearly, some of my audience has been
following Dan Crenshaw since because I got
a bunch of e-mails this morning about an interview
that Dan Crenshaw gave to Fox and Friends.
I believe it was yesterday.
And I want to go through some of the things
in this interview because it actually seems
Dan Crenshaw's a dangerous guy in a very particular
way.
He seems not just uninformed, but actually
delusional.
And he presents his delusional, uninformed
ideas in an eloquent and sort of Ben Shapiro
type way where it's like, wow, he seems so
convinced that this is so obviously the truth
that it clearly must be even when what he's
saying doesn't really make any sense.
And as a result, he's become a real conservative
hero to a lot of right wingers who are just
looking to have red meat thrown at them and
talking points that they can use.
So this is it's scary to see that he's almost
becoming like a pseudo intellectual figure
among some on the right.
And I know you'll be scared by that idea,
but I want to dig into what just a couple
of the things he said yesterday during this
Fox and Friends interview.
So first of all, here he is railing against
Marxism, which he says there's been a concerted
effort to bring to the United States for decades.
Take a listen to this.
Always part of the plan.
It has been for decades, actually.
And it started well back in two until day
when Marxism made its way into the United
States in the 60s.
And they're always looking to take advantage
of some kind of situation to make people think
that their country is evil so that they can
justify their own Marxist revolution.
That is what's happening here.
And you can't be blind to that.
The plan for decades for Marxism to come to
the United States in order to make people
believe the United States is evil in order
to cause a Marxist revolution.
So what he's taking here is like maybe a one
percent accurate idea that in Marxism there
is this idea that when capitalism fails, there
will be a revolution which will usher in a
Marxist state.
That that that's a Marxist idea.
That's true.
But you've really got to break down what he's
saying piece by piece because it's a gift
gallop.
It's just Gish Gallop is a debate term where
you just throw out a bunch of stuff.
And particularly on Fox News, Brian, Kill
Meat is not going to be the guy to go through
step by step.
So first, he says there has been a plan for
decades.
Who's whose plan?
A plan by whom?
Where was it crafted?
Because the Marxists themselves are almost
completely nonexistent.
Like, there's not even that many socialists.
Most socialists are not actually Marxists
either.
Marxism has been around as a theory since
the eighteen hundreds.
So who exactly has been working on this plan
for decades to bring this eighteen hundreds
idea to the United States for decades?
And if they've been doing it for decades,
they've clearly failed miserably because there
are still almost no Marxists at all in the
United States and certainly no Marxists in
positions of power.
So.
So that part is not true.
Then he sort of starts taking advantage of
this idea of the left wants to make the U.S.
look bad or portray the U.S. as evil.
And this is maybe easier to do right now because
the left is in the opposition when you have
Donald Trump, this wild authoritarian surrounded
by right wing nuts in power.
We are rightly pointing out that a lot is
going wrong in the country.
But that doesn't mean we're Marxists or socialists.
I'm certainly neither.
And he's taking advantage of the situation
that has left the left, that has placed the
left in a position of having to say the U.S.
is a bad actor.
In some cases, the U.S. is a bad actor on
coronavirus because of the failed response
from Trump and mostly Republican governors.
That doesn't mean the country is in and of
itself bad.
That's a very simplistic and childish sort
of way to categorize countries.
It's cartoonish thinking.
The real view is the United States is a country,
given how rich we are, could be a force for
so much more good than it is.
And that's what we want to get back to.
And it doesn't.
A socialist takeover or a Marxist uprising?
So again, Gish Gallop from Dan Crenshaw.
Here's another clip.
We're Crenshaw blames the police brutality,
the anti police brutality protesters for the
spike in cases in Texas rather than Texas
reopening too early.
Let's take a look at that.
But we're gonna get through this.
It's a virus without a vaccine.
We always knew this kind of thing would happen,
especially when we had tens of thousands of
people in the streets just a couple weeks
ago.
Featherston just sort of surprised no one
over 300 cities, Deringer plus cities had
some type of rioting, looting, protests happening.
How do people not link those two?
In fact, I've seen reports saying no proof
that the riots in the streets and the protests
led to the rise of Corona virus.
Well, you'd have to suspend logic to think
that, yeah, don't believe your lying eyes.
Everybody wants to say it was a few people
hanging out at bars that caused this.
That's not true.
Listen, Texas has been reopening since May
1st.
OK, we've been getting back to normalcy since
May 1st.
And everything was declining as as a result,
cases were declining.
This spikes happened after tens of thousands
of people got together in close proximity.
Again, there's nothing wrong with saying that.
That's that's just the truth.
And we're just dealing with it now.
It's not it's not about blaming anybody.
It's just about being honest with with causes
and effects.
So notice that Brian Kill Medes says, you
know, we had rioting and looting and protesting
like what we mostly had was actually protesting.
This is a linguistic tool that's used.
You first mentioned the rioting and the looting
and then you mentioned the protesting.
Always frame things as mostly violent when
you're against the message.
But the real meat here is the cases, which
Dan Crenshaw says is him being honest.
Listen, we've got to be honest.
It's the anti police brutality protests that
spiked cases.
Now, I said up front.
The virus knows no political ideology.
The virus doesn't care whether you're protesting
against lockdowns or you're protesting against
police brutality.
Both can spike cases.
The facts happen to be that the anti lockdown
protests were mostly people not wearing masks.
Whereas the anti police brutality protests
were mostly people wearing masks.
Not everybody you saw if you masks at the
anti lockdown protests and you saw a few people
without masks at the anti police brutality
protests.
But by and large, people were wearing masks
and the masks work.
Even Sean Hannity set it on his program last
night.
So in New York City and in Boston, we had
huge protests and we didn't have a spike.
And in fact, we see a continued decline in
New York and Massachusetts in other places.
You had protests and there has been a spike.
And the spike appears to be mostly because
of people without masks in restaurants.
We're hearing about outbreaks at nail salons
and the like and even Texas.
His own governor said we probably opened bars
too early.
Which is certainly an admission that things
have not gone exactly right.
So I have my ideology is truth and my ideology
is health.
I was worried there would be a major spike
because of the protests.
Fortunately, the protesters widely wore masks,
and it doesn't seem as though those protests
caused the big spike.
Conversely, we're starting to see some elements
surrounding Tulsa, Oklahoma, that are seeing
more rapidly increasing cases.
That could be because of Trump's rally at
which 60, 200 people crowded together, well,
crowded.
There was there was some room because it was
so empty.
But many of them were crowded together without
wearing masks.
Let's just tell the truth and don't fall for
Dan Crenshaw's B.S.